hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play real life of the
game now I'm at my buddy Matthias place
and he got his hands on the beta to this
ridiculously cool looking game you guys
are gonna love it it's pretty darn crazy
alright anyway we're gonna get into this
okay
alright woo I really like this looks
like we get to design our own guy here
what the hell what the hell whoa that is
me that is me okay I don't know if this
activated Facebook or something
but hey Matthias hey come here check
this out dude let me look this what the
hedge Bergin me go take a run okay all
right have fun I guess yeah sorry about
the interruption guides my hand weird
are you okay looks like it's about time
to get into the game as I'm playing
myself the man I gotta say this looks
really real like incredibly real I don't
know if this next generation or
something but now we know where the
title came from
okay the controls feel pretty decent I
mean kind of sticky kind of like
Minecraft but but it's not that bad oh
oh I just got infinitely better than
minecraft because I start with a gun
okay let's see if I can shoot any random
people around here umm a let's go up to
this guy
hahahahahaha sweet mark what whoa look
at that must have gotten into my
Facebook friends this game isn't very
good about privacy graphics aside I do
not like that
now whatever did you kill him okay let's
Rob this loser see if he's got anything
all my stuff's at home I'm in my running
here that's not my problem
okay I'll teach you there haha yeah
alright okay looks like we got a
cutscene coming along
sweet alright let's see if we can
upgrade this gun here and wait woah
this is so weird this looks just like
his apartment holy crap
he must have submitted dim pictures to
the developers or something in order to
get the beta I have no idea what he did
but I mean okay I I actually heard
something there I know I always say that
I hear something in these games that I'm
playing but I actually heard something
out there I don't know what that was
okay anyway let's see it one didn't whoa
wait a minute
oh my god it's so real thanks so much
for watching if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more than please check
out Matthias his channel he did pretty
much everything on this video and he's
got a special alternate ending to this
video over there just click on his
lovely face a lot of work was put into
this so please share with your friends
and do whatever you can to spread the
word thanks again everyone and I will
see you in the next video bye bye